the equation y is equal to the square
root of 2x minus 10 has a y-intercept of
0 negative 10 and you see that from this
equation the y-intercept is where do you
intersect the y axis or what happens to
Y when X is equal to 0 when X is equal
to 0 this part of the expression is
equal to 0 and you're left with Y is
equal to negative 10 rearrange the
equation to express X in terms of Y so
I've got put this on my scratch pad here
so that I can work it out so really we
just want to think about we just want to
solve for X here we want to rearrange to
express X in terms of Y so let me just
rewrite it Y is equal to the square root
of 2x minus 10 so we want to isolate the
X on the right hand side so the first
thing we might want to do is just add 10
to both sides let me add 10 to both
sides that gets rid of the 10 on the
right hand side and we are left with y
plus 10 y actually let me let me just
keep let me just keep track of the color
so you can see what I'm up to y plus 10
y plus 10 is equal to the square root of
2x now let's see if we let this X let's
square both sides here so let's square
the left hand side let's square the
right hand side we of course anything we
do to one side we have to do to the
other otherwise equality will no longer
be true and we are going to have y plus
10 y plus 10 squared is equal to the
square root the square root of 2 x
squared is just going to be 2x is equal
to 2x and now we can divide both sides
by 2 divide both sides by 2 and we are
left with X is equal to y plus 10
squared over 2 so let me write that out
let me actually type that in into the
program right over here so X was equal
to y plus 10 squared over 2 which is
exactly what I wrote down on my scratch
pad and then they say what is the
equations X
intercept so let's just let's just
remind ourselves what's going on here so
this curve or this equation could
describe a curve that looks something
like this so that's my y-axis this is my
x-axis and let's say the curve it might
look something like this it might look
something like might look something like
that
so we already figured out its
y-intercept its y-intercept is where
does it intersect the y-axis and we
already figured out that's when X is
equal to zero Y is equal to negative 10
now we want to figure out its
x-intercept so that's essentially what x
value do we get to when y is equal to
zero so what x value do we get to when y
is equal to zero
let me just let me clear these out just
so this doesn't we don't get distracted
by this right over here well when Y is
equal to zero when y is equal to zero X
is going to be equal to 10 squared over
2 X is equal to 10 squared over 2 0 plus
10 is 10 squared 100 over 2 which is
going to be equal to 50 so we're at the
point X is 50 and Y is 0 so that's this
right over here the x-intercept is 50
when X is 50 we clearly see that Y is
equal to zero so let's also put that in
there so what is the equations
x-intercept so when X is 50 y Y is 0 and
we could check our answer and we got it
right